The National Academy of Sciences was
formed by President Abraham Lincoln
to provide independent
objective advice to the nation
on matters related to science and
technology.
For many years its healthcare component,
The Institute of Medicine,
which recently became The Academy of
Medicine, was instrumental in raising
the alarm that U.S. healthcare has
the problems we've been discussing.
The institute has called for
a new, learning health system.
We don't have time to discuss that in
detail, but here's a simple health
infomatics perspective that shows how
electronic records, if they're adopted
and can share data, become a source of
information from actual patient care.
It can then be aggregated and analyzed
to develop new knowledge, that in turn,
through an informatics powered feedback
loop, leads to continuous improvement.